ça y est après deux mois et demi de
confinement une étape importante vient
d'être actée vers un retour à la normale
dans la capitale russe
un calendrier sur trois semaines a été
dévoilée par le maire de moscou ont
d'accord avec le gouvernement
à partir du 9 juin le régime de
confinement et les laissez passer sont
annulés les horaires de promenade sont
également annulés des résidents de la
ville y compris les moscovites âgées de
plus de 65 ans et ceux qui souffrent de
maladies chroniques peuvent sortir sans
restriction vaquer à leurs affaires et
visiter les lieux publics les
organisations non gouvernementales les
studios de cinéma les studios
d'enregistrement les instituts de
recherche peuvent également reprendre
leur travail
les théâtres les salles de concert et
les cirques peuvent organiser des
répétitions de groupes artistiques des
restrictions sur les visites au
cimetière sont également levé dans une
semaine le 16 juin
les restrictions concernant les soins
dentaires non urgents seront annulés les
bibliothèques les agences immobilières
les agences de location
les agences de publicité les bureaux de
consultants et autres entreprises qui
fournissent des services aux individus
et aux entreprises pourront reprendre
leur travail
en résumé donc à partir de ce 9 juin
plus besoin de laisser passer donc plus
de restrictions de déplacements les
coiffeurs et salons de beauté sont
autorisés à rouvrir une semaine plus
tard le 16 les terrasses les musées les
bibliothèques pour en rouvrir leurs
portes et enfin le 23
autour des cafés et restaurants piscine
et salle de sport concernant la
réouverture des frontières par contre la
reprise des vols commerciaux n'est
toujours pas d'actualité malgré tout un
assouplissement des restrictions de
voyage pour certaines catégories de
personnes a été décidé je vous propose
d'écouter le premier ministre russe le
décret du gouvernement qui a été signée
permet aux citoyens russes de partir à
l'étranger pour prendre soin de membres
de leur famille malade résidant dans un
autre pays ainsi que pour des motifs
professionnels ou d'études les citoyens
russes qui ont besoin de recevoir des
soins médicaux hors de russie pourront
également se rendre à l'étranger
les ressortissants étrangers qui
envisagent de se faire soigner dans des
établissements de santé russes pourront
entrer sur le territoire de russie
les gens dont les membres de la famille
proche tuteurs et curateurs ayant besoin
de soins habitants russie seront
également autorisés à entrer dans le
pays une fois on le voit l'état du
confinement ce dessert et ce même si le
port du masque et des gants reste
toujours obligatoire attention cependant
le calendrier a été donné à titre
indicatif les autorités se réserve le
droit de le modifier en fonction de
l'évolution de la pandémie
une chose paraît clair nos mains on le
voit à travers ce calendrier
tout est fait pour que les restrictions
soient levés à l'occasion de la grande
parade militaire prévu le 24 juin